I am the arbiter of justice the voice of
God placed here by our Lord Jesus Christ
himself to decide what is good and what
is equal klonoa was on out there I hear
it every day you don't know you've never
seen the real thing you have nothing to
compare no point of reference you look
at this thing we've asked you to do you
think oh that's eat somebody dies murder
bad but when I look do you know what I
see do you want to guess good I see good
because I'm looking at the big picture
the outcome the end result I'm not
caught up in the minutia I mean we're
talking about a child a living breathing
human being don't depend on you for
everything life for understanding it
will be your god-given responsibility to
leave this child on the path of
righteousness to make him a soldier for
God Almighty what a gift you could give
him the Heavenly Father from your own
body can you think of anything more
miraculous if somebody has to die to
bring about this miracle so be it people
have died before it's not the first time
there are plenty of sinners clock in the
streets drug dealers pedophiles rapists
we'll find someone who want to be best
someone who deserves to go but they
generate or make the world a better
place cleaning it up washing the way the
stains of one sinner and replacing it
goodness and light and innocence of a
child of Christ yours to shape and mold
what do you say is there anything evil
in that